[Musique]
les collectivités territoriales
françaises sont mobilisés depuis le
début de l'agression russe contre
l'Ukraine avec tout d'abord l'accueil
des 115000 réfugiés Ukrainiens qui sont
présents sur notre territoire les
collectivités ont aussi participé à
l'aide d'urgence en direction de
l'Ukraine pour fournir des biens de
première nécessité et aujourd'hui elle
réfléchissent elle travaille à la
reconstruction du crâne avec des
compétences et une expertise importante
dans l'eau et l'assainissement dans la
gestion des déchets dans la
reconstruction concrète des bâtiments et
cela donne de la perspective cela donne
de l'espoir pour les élus locaux mais
aussi pour les populations le mot qui
est revenu beaucoup lors des auditions
c'est concret opérationnel on est dans
des échanges extrêmement pratiques et
qui correspond à la vie des élus de tous
les jours c'est peut-être pour ça que
que les mers et les responsables de
collectivités ont été les plus à même de
relever ce défi parce que nous le côté
pratique c'est le quotidien c'est tous
les jours et c'est vraiment de ça qu'on
besoin les Ukrainiens la coopération
décentralisée c'est extrêmement simple
beaucoup de communes ou de comportement
contact le Sénat français évidemment et
demande à avoir un lien avec une
collectivité ukrainienne quand ils ont
déjà un lien le problème ne se pose pas
quand ils n'ont pas de lien nous nous
passons par la Rada qui elle-même
centralise si je puis dire les demandes
et on essaye de mettre en contact des
communes ou des départements français
avec des communes des régions
ukrainiennes pour qu'il y ait des
partenariats des jumelages et qu'à
partir de là cette coopération
décentralisée fonctionne il faudra
veiller maintenant à vraiment bien
organiser je pense la coordination de
tous les opérateurs surtout sans se
substituer et au contraire bravo et
j'admire le fait que toutes ces aides
s'inscrivent dans le temps long et rien
de s'essouffle on continue on continue
et c'est bien parce que la guerre dure
beaucoup plus que prévu et c'est
miraculeux que rien ne s'essouffle